>> Tucker: THE BRETT KAVANAUGH
STORY HAS HEARD IT FROM A LOT OF
PEOPLE ALREADY BUT THE BIG
VICTIM MAY BE AMERICA'S BASIC
SENSE OF JUSTICE.
NORMS LIKE THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, DUE PROCESS AND
FAIRNESS ITSELF HAVE ALL BEEN
SHOVED ASIDE IN A POLITICAL
FRENZY.
THE QUESTION IS, COULD
TOMORROW'S HEARING START TO UNDO
THE DAMAGE?
JOINING US NOW AS A MAN WHO HAS
RELENTLESSLY DEFENDED FAIRNESS
AT A GREAT PERSONAL COST, AND HE
IS OF COURSE ALAN DERSHOWITZ,
AUTHOR OF THE CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHING TRUMP.
AND WE WELCOME HIM NOW.
PROFESSOR, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
SO, WHAT DO YOU WANT NOT AS A
PARTISAN OR SOMEONE WHO VOTES
WITH DEMOCRATS BUT AS SOMEONE
WHO CARES ABOUT PRESERVING OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM?
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SEE IN THESE
HEARINGS TOMORROW?
>> I WANT TO SEE THE GREATEST
ENGINE OF TRUTH EVER INVENTED,
NAMELY USED A CROSS EXAMINATION.
AND I'M WORRIED THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
THE WOMAN WHO HAS BEEN HIRED TO
CONDUCT THE CROSS-EXAMINATION
HAS PROBABLY RARELY EVER
CROSS-EXAMINED ANYBODY.
SHE'S A PROSECUTOR.
PROSECUTORS PUT ON CASES AND
MOSTLY DEFENDANTS DON'T TAKE THE
STAND.
SO THIS IS A WOMAN WITH 20 YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE AS A PROSECUTOR
BUT NO EXPERIENCE AS A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, SO I DON'T THINK SHE'S
THE RIGHT PERSON TO QUESTION
DR. FORD.
THERE NEEDS TO BE CROSS
EXAMINATION NOT ONLY OF HER BUT
OF THE NEW MICHAEL AVENATTI
ALLEGATION.
THAT AFFIDAVIT IS SO DEEPLY
FLAWED AND OPEN-ENDED THAT GOOD
DEFENSE ATTORNEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO TEAR THAT APART IN 30
SECONDS.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE LAW
THAT ANYONE WOULD FILE AN
AFFIDAVIT LIKE THAT FILLED WITH
HARRIS' HEARSAY.
BUT THERE WERE WITNESSES AND
PEOPLE TOLD ME, I HAVE BEEN TEN
TIMES.
I WENT BACK AND I KNEW THERE
WERE RAPES GOING ON BUT I WENT
BACK TO THE PARTY.
THIS IS WAS SUCH A DEEPLY FOUGHT
AFTER DAY -- >> Tucker: IS
THIS AFFIDAVIT, DOES IT CROSSED
SOME LINE WHERE THERE COULD BE
PROFESSIONAL QUANT SEQUENCES?
>> WHY DON'T THEY GET REACHES
THAT LINE BUT IT CERTAINLY IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY WEAK AFFIDAVIT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO DRAFTED IT
AND WHO FILLED IN THE GAPS.
WAS SHE ASHLEY'S SAYS BY
KAVANAUGH THE JUDGE, DID HE SEE
IT, WAS HE IN THE ROOM?
IF THERE WERE GANG LIKE THAT,
HOW DID IT NOT GET TO THE POLIC
POLICE?
ANY LAWYER WHO LOVES
CROSS-EXAMINATION WOULD LOVE
NOTHING MORE THAN TO EXAMINE A
WITNESS HOLDING THAT AFFIDAVIT
IN HIS HANDS AND SAYING, HERE?
HERE.
BUT HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
ALL HE CARES ABOUT IS GETTING
THE HEADLINE, MAYBE SHE WILL
TESTIFY AND MAYBE SHE WON'T.
BUT IF SHE TESTIFIES, SHE WILL
BE CROSS-EXAMINED IN A VERY
EFFECTIVE MANNER BY THE CROSS
EXAMINER.
>> WHY NOT ASK REAL QUESTIONS
AND WHY NOT SEE THE CLAIMS ALIGN
COMMON SENSE, THEY BECOME SO
INTENSE THAT EVERYONE IS AFRAID
TO ASK REAL QUESTIONS?
>> IT WAS TERRIBLE BECAUSE SHE
HAD A WOMAN SAY ON TELEVISION
THAT IT WAS SEXIST TO HAVE
APPOINTED A WOMAN LAWYER.
SHE WOULD HAVE SAID IT WAS
SEXIST TO APPOINT A MALE LAWYER.
YOU NEED A GENERAL NEUTRAL ROBOT
NOW TO CROSS EXAMINE IF YOU WANT
TO AVOID CLAIMS OF SEXISM, IT'S
A "NO" WIN.
CROSS-EXAMINATION MUST BE
EFFECTIVE AND IT MUST BE TOUGH.
IT HAS TO BE RESPECTFUL.
YOU CAN BE RESPECTFUL AND TOUGH
BUT DO NOT PULL PUNCHES.
THERE IS SO MUCH AT STAKE HERE.
A MAN'S LIFE, HIS REPUTATION,
HIS CAREER, HIS FAMILY, THE
WOMEN AND THEIR CREDIBILITY.
THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA HAVING A
JUST SITTING ON THE
SUPREME COURT, THE STAKES ARE
TOO HIGH.
I DON'T AGREE WITH REPUBLICANS
THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE A VOTE ON
FRIDAY, I DON'T AGREE WITH
REPUBLICANS THAT THERE SHOULD
HAVE TO BE A CONTINUING
BACKGROUND CHECK.
NO REASON NOT TO HAVE A
TIME SHOULD NOT BE THE
DETERMINING FACTOR WHEN YOU ARE
PUTTING SOMEBODY ON THE
SUPREME COURT FOR A LIFETIME.
TRUTH HAS TO BE THE DETERMINING
FACTOR.
WE CAN'T LET THIS BOAT HAVE BEEN
UNTIL WE KNOW WHETHER THESE
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS DID OR DID
NOT OCCUR AND THERE CAN'T BE A